the Justice Department indicted 12
Russian military officers for tampering
with the 2016 u.s. election the
indictment alleges the Russian agents
hacked into the Hillary Clinton
presidential campaign and the Democratic
Party and then released tens of
thousands of stolen emails Deputy
Attorney General Rod Rosenstein
announcing the charges moments after
President Trump and Queen Elizabeth
began their first ever meeting and less
than 72 hours before mr. Trump's high
stakes summit with Russian President
Vladimir Putin the White House did not
issue any condemnation of the attack
Errol Barnett has more on this from the
White House Erol good morning good
morning team yes the United States
government made its case clear on Friday
Russia conducted a sophisticated
operation to undermine the democratic
process and really throw a wrench in the
u.s. electoral system now some lawmakers
are calling for the president to call
off his upcoming meeting with President
Putin the units engaged in active cyber
operations to interfere in the 2016
presidential election Deputy Attorney
General rod Rosenstein explained the
charges brought by a grand jury stemming
from the special council's ongoing
investigation into Russia 11 other
defendants are charged with conspiring
to hack into computers steal documents
and release those documents with the
intent to interfere in the election the
targets include Democratic Party groups
including its national and congressional
campaign committees as well as the
Hillary Clinton campaign the indictment
alleges that on July 27 2016
hackers attempted to access Hillary
Clinton's personal accounts hours after
then Canada Trump said this Russia if
you're listening I hope you're able to
find the 30,000 emails that are missing
according to the indictment Russian
intelligence agents sent phishing emails
to people like Clinton campaign chairman
John Podesta tricking him to click a
link that gave hackers access to his
email account
they then stole fifty thousand of his
emails the same technique gave hackers
access to Democratic part
servus the Russians then leaked that
information much of it damaging to
Hillary Clinton through to fake online
personas DC leaks and guseva 2.0 before
the indictments were announced the
president criticized the Russia probes
validity I would call it the rig to
witch-hunt Rosenstein briefed the
president before his overseas trip which
will include a meeting Monday with
Russian President Putin important for
the president to know what information
we've uncovered because he's got to make
very important decisions for the country
president Trump was asked if he will
bring up election hacking during the
one-on-one I will absolutely bring that
up I don't think you'll have any G I did
it I did it you got me Democrats voiced
skepticism about that the president and
his team are not willing to make the
facts of this indictment a top priority
of the meeting in Helsinki and the
summit should be cancelled but the White
House has made clear the meeting with
Putin is still on a schedule the White
House also highlighting the fact that no
Americans were charged or anyone from
the Trump campaign implicated meantime
the Russian government denied these
allegations claiming they're designed to
quote spoil the atmosphere before the
russian-american summit Michelle Errol
Barnett thank you